Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question d'Ulysse,
qui me demande :
« Y a-t-il des communautés autochtones au Québec
où les gens vivent en autosuffisance? »
J'aimerais tourner ta question et dire
plutôt « Quand les Premières Nations
ont-elles perdu leur capacité à s'autosuffire? »
Il ne faut pas oublier que la raison
pour laquelle on est dans des réserves
ou dans des communautés,
c'est malheureusement parce qu'il y a eu
des politiques gouvernementales,
il y a eu la Loi sur les Indiens et il y a eu une pratique mise en place pour détruire notre capacité
à nous autosuffire. Les Mohawks
ont eu des politiques mises en place pour
les empêcher de vendre
le produit de leur agriculture.
Les Innus, par exemple, on nous a empêchés
d'aller pêcher dans la rivière à côté
de laquelle on habitait.
C'était des pratiques qui ont été mises en place
pour nous rendre dépendants, justement,
de l'économie qu'on dit canadienne.
Et aujourd'hui, on en voit les effets.
Mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va accepter ça
sans rien faire, et encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup de communautés travaillent
très fort à devenir autosuffisantes
au niveau économique et au niveau
territorial. Je pense qu'on ne peut pas
voir encore le même effet qu'on avait
il y a cent ans,
mais on voit qu'il y a un désir
de pouvoir s'affranchir de cette politique
qui nous a justement
mis des bâtons dans les roues
il y a plus de 100 ans.
Alors, merci beaucoup pour ta question.
J'espère y avoir bien répondu.
J'espère que vous n'allez pas hésiter
à nous en envoyer d'autres et à partager
cette vidéo.
Passez une belle semaine!